figure live bonjour et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau point de situation sur la guerre
en Ukraine avec une contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui a-t-elle démarré où en
est-elle on va en discuter aujourd'hui
et je suis avec Alexis faire chaque
bonjour Alexis bonjour Vincent merci
d'être avec nous adjoint au pôle actu
avec vous on va décrypter un peu tout ce
qui se passe sur ce front voilà sur
cette ligne de France grâce aux cartes
bien sûr du service infographies que
vous pourrez retrouver sur le site du
Figaro première question Alexis est-ce
qu'on peut faire un petit point général
sur la situation en ce moment oui alors
il y a une actualité depuis on va dire
48 heures c'est que sur le front et
notamment sur le front sud on va le
définir ce que c'est tout à l'heure mais
visiblement les les
Ukrainiens repassent à l'offensive voilà
ça c'est vraiment l'actualité on va dire
à 48 heures mais il faut après faut se
dézoomer un peu et si vous voulez la
fameuse contre offensive qu'on attendait
depuis des mois on estime qu'elle a
commencé le 8 juin c'est à peu près le
problème c'est que les
Ukrainiens il y a pas un jour ils ont
dit ils ont appuyé sur le bouton
ça a commencé mais si vous voulez qu'on
regarde les mouvements de troupes etc on
peut estimer que la contre-offensive a
commencé le 8 juin donc ça fait
maintenant quasiment quasiment de moi
finalement et la la remarque générale
qu'on peut faire en 8 mois c'est qu'il y
a pas eu de grandes percées
ukrainienne et que la ligne de front
pour un point lecteur qui ne connaît pas
toutes les localités qui sont des
petites localités de la ligne de front
il regarde la carte et la carte
globalement
n'a pas tellement changé on va voir que
quand on regarde dans le détail il y a
des subtilités mais mais mais on
retrouve cette forme qui finalement
commence à la connaître puisque c'est la
même forme
depuis assez longtemps on va revenir
dans le détail après mais cette espèce
de
de corridor si vous voulez qui va de la
Crimée et qui remonte jusqu'à la région
de lougance en passant par la région de
Kerson qui est coupé par le par le
Nieppe puis la région de la purudija
puis de nietz puis puis l'ougance et il
y a une forme de croissance comme ça si
vous voulez et avec un front sud qui
globalement va de Carson
à l'ouest de deniek par facilité on
appellera ça le front de vaporidia parce
qu'en fait la grande région centrale
c'est celle de la poésie et puis
cibler dans l'angle de ce croissant il y
a la région de doniesk avec un point
chaud qui est qui sont les combats
autour de backmouth et puis il y a un
front dont on parle moins qu'elles font
de l'ougance
un peu plus au nord qu'elle a la branche
verticale de la des territoires conquis
par les Russes et là c'est un front
important parce que vous voyez que c'est
à proximité de carquif qui est la
deuxième ville du crâne alors évidemment
aujourd'hui absolument pas question que
les que les Russes
envisagent même de reprendre cette ville
mais malgré tout c'est un front qui ne
qui ne faut pas oublier donc là c'est
trois parties du front avec un peu plus
stratégique même si encore une fois les
les combats n'ont pas lieu à cet endroit
là il y a la question de la Crimée qui
reste probablement dans dans ces
territoires
Ukrainiens
occupé par les Russes c'est la région
cette péninsule qui est la qui est la
plus stratégique parce qu'elle est
finalement couper du territoire russe
lui-même par la mère d'Azov et il y a
juste vous savez un des trois qui
s'appelle des trois de Kirch avec un
pont qui est devenu aujourd'hui célèbre
qui est si stratégique pour les Russes
une sorte de cordon ombilicale qui est
ici je vais vous montrer hop sur la
carte là et qui a en plus explosé une
explosion sur ce deuxième fois après la
deuxième fois il avait une première il y
a en juillet le dernier d'ailleurs donc
là il y a une deuxième attaque et vous
voyez que les Russes d'un point de vue
logistique pour eux c'est compliqué
d'atteindre la Crimée sinon il faut
qu'il fasse le tour par la terre c'est
juste ment par les territoires qu'ils
ont occupés évidemment d'un peu de
stratégique ça n'est pas rien et donc il
faut avoir en tête que la grande
offensive ukrainienne dont on parle
depuis des mois son objectif principal
c'est de couper ce corridor terrestre
qui va de la Crimée
au territoire russe c'est en fait une
attaque au niveau de zapporigia vous on
le voit là avec avec ces petits crans
bleus en fait on les voit ces petits
points bleus qui sont les zones reprises
depuis de mois par les ukrainiens et on
verra qu'en fait il y a il y a princip
il y a trois points d'attaque principaux
Ukrainiens le plus à l'ouest et
aujourd'hui le le plus important depuis
48 heures c'est
au sud
de la de la ville ukrainienne d'orif
donc les Ukrainiens poussent vers le sud
il y a un deuxième point qui est à
cheval entre les deux au blases de
zappéjia et doniak et là on le voit pas
sur la carte mais la bazarière de
l'Ukraine pour cette contre-attaque
c'est la ville de velikano
encore les Ukrainiens ont annoncé avoir
repris au sud de cette ville hier un
village qui s'appelle star omayork
donc là sur la carte c'est là où les
Ukrainiens ont le plus avancé parce
qu'en fait il y avait une sorte de
saillant russe avant et les Ukrainiens
début juin ont commencé à attaquer par
là et puis le troisième endroit qui se
verra moins sur la carte mais qui est
tout à fait
essentiel
c'est c'est la ville de de backgrout
alors là on le voit pas très bien sur la
carte
voilà tout en haut
de le blast de Denis les Russes ont
réussi je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
mais à reprendre cette ville
surtout avec les mercenaires de de
Wagner
ça leur a pris des mois mais la ville a
été officiellement prise à la fin du
mois de mai et donc là les Ukrainiens
c'est le troisième axe d'attaque
ukrainien c'est finalement
d'attaquer les flancs russes autour de
backmouth au nord et au sud de la ville
pourquoi parce que la ville de bac mouth
qui est traversée par un par un canal
enfin il y a un canal qui passe juste à
l'ouest de makmouth la ville de bac mout
et plutôt un niveau de terrain
relativement bas et au nord et au sud et
d'ailleurs aussi à l'ouest il y a des
hauteurs et en fait toujours pareil qui
contrôle les hauteurs ensuite gagne la
bataille c'est la grande militaire qui a
des qui a des siècles et c'est
exactement ce qu'on va essayer de faire
les Russes pendant longtemps
ils n'ont pas réussi c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont dû prendre la ville
finalement rue par rue plutôt que
d'essayer plutôt qu'une
pince stratégie de pince honneur et au
sud et après progressivement les Russes
ont réussi à s'emparer de quelques
hauteurs pas de toutes les hauteurs et
ce que font les Ukrainiens aujourd'hui
c'est d'essayer de reprendre les
hauteurs alors au nord pour l'instant il
n'y a pas tellement d'avancé
ukrainiennes mais aussi il y a une
avancée importante puisque après des
semaines de combat il semblerait que les
Ukrainiens ont repris une petite ville
qui est le long du canal dont je vous
parlais s'appelle climicha et
et cette ville petite ville de kimchka
et
entouré de hauteur et c'est auteurs
aujourd'hui sont ukrainiennes et donc ça
on peut imaginer que c'est le début
d'une action ukrainienne pour reprendre
plus globalement la ville de backmouth
mais attention tout ça c'est au
conditionnel il y a plein de conditions
on se rappelle par exemple que les
Russes au début avaient tenté cette
stratégie de reprise des hauteurs de
pinces et finalement les Ukrainiens
avaient réussi à en effet à se défendre
finalement se défendent à maintenir leur
flanc et donc les Russes avaient dû les
mercenaires de Wagner avait dû avancer
directement par l'est en prenant la
ville de bac mouth rue par rue dans un
combat urbain qui est par nature
extrêmement meurtrier donc pour
l'instant en fait il y a 48 heures les
Ukrainiennes disent rien donc les Russes
ont
si vous lisez les agences de presse
officielles russes comme tasse ou les
déclarations du ministère de la défense
ils ont reconnu et même Poutine au
sommet
africain ces Petersburg ils ont avoué
les Russes qui avaient des des
opérations en cours qui étaient
particulières intensité
ils ont même reconnu que les Ukrainiens
dans le sud donc là on revient sur le
frontzaporigia prédorifs avaient avancé
vers le sud de 2,5 km les Russes disent
on a repoussé l'attaque donc on a
repoussé les Ukrainiens
les Ukrainiens eux ne disent rien
officiellement c'est leur stratégie de
communication quand il passe à
l'offensive il ferme les égoutiers de la
communication on n'a plus rien et puis
de l'autre côté on a la presse
américaine
qui elle y a eu quelques sources du
Pentagone dans le Washington Post et
dans le New York Times qui estime qu'on
est là depuis 48 heures au début du
lancement de l'offensive majeur à
l'intérieur de la contre-offensive
c'est-à-dire que quand vous faites une
contre-offensive
il y a plusieurs phases il y a une phase
notamment
qui sont portées à l'épaule vous avez
des des ouvrages en béton armé qui sont
là pour arrêter les chars vous avez des
tranchées à l'ancienne et on a vu des
combats d'infanterie dans les tranchées
vous avez les drones qui sont à la fois
des des drones d'observation pour la
retirer des drones suscitent qui
permettent de viser directement
des blindés et notamment
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui du drone
landset qui est un drone russe et qui
arrive rarement à détruire complètement
des des blindés ou des chars
Ukrainiens mais qui arrivent souvent à
détériorer ou abîmer de tels de telle
charte qui qui ensuite ne sont pas
opérationnels pendant quelques jours
quelques semaines ou quelques mois et
puis vous avez aussi la supériorité
aérienne russe qui qui même si elle
n'est pas même si elle n'est pas
flagrante les l'aviation russe n'est pas
en mesure d'aller en profondeur dans le
territoire ukrainien parce que il peur
une défense antiérienne ukrainienne qui
est solide et en revanche sur la ligne
de front
les Russes ont encore des avions
d'atacosol des hélicoptères de combat
pendant toute la première phase de la
guerre
les hélicoptères russes c'était demandé
à quoi il servait c'est-à-dire qu'ils
étaient
détruits systématiquement sans aucun
résultat apparent là depuis la
contrefensive de juin on a été assez
étonné d'observer des camos des camov 52
qui qui parvenait grâce à leur missile
antichard à certains résultats contre
les blindés et les chars
Ukrainiens donc vous voyez il y a tout
un tas d'armes une armée c'est un
système c'est pas souvent on a tendance
parce qu'il y a des armements comme ça
qui sont un peu symboliques à penser
qu'il y a une arme magique etc tout un
système et donc les Russes pendant très
longtemps étaient complètement
désorganisés là ça se voit qu'ils ont
davantage préparer leur leur défense
maintenant est-ce que l'offensive qui
s'observe depuis 48 heures va permettre
d'abord une véritable percée des lignes
de défense russe bah ça on ne le sait
pas encore et puis même s'il y avait une
percée après la percée il faut
développer l'offensive et là il faut de
nouvelles forces et après avoir
développé la percée il faut consolider
bref on en est vous voyez qu'on en est
au tout début de de la contre-offensive
ce que j'observe simplement c'est que
alors rappelez-vous on remonte un peu
dans le temps il y avait eu deux
précédentes contre-offensives l'année
dernière
l'une à Carson tout à l'ouest du
dispositif russe et l'une tout au nord
du dispositif à Cardiff et peut-être que
l'erreur d'interprétation et d'analyse
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a on s'est un
peu dit à la normalité c'est de
reprendre autant de terrain voilà donc
qu'est-ce qui s'était passer finalement
à partir de septembre les Ukrainiens
avaient réalisé une sorte de c'était une
sorte de petite Blake ils avaient repris
je me souviens qu'il doit se mettre
quelques dix mille kilomètres carrés
c'est parti en bleu qu'on peut voir ici
il est allé jusqu'à criminat et ça ça
s'était joué en quelques semaines et de
la même manière il y avait eu une
contre-offensive à l'ouest dans la
région de Kerson où les
Ukrainiens avaient réussi à reprendre
tous les territoires qui étaient situés
sur la rive droite du Nièvre donc c'est
à dire à l'ouest du Nièvre et donc les
Russes avaient dû quitter c'est une
sorte d'humiliation politique la grande
ville de Carson qui était la seule
capitale régionale qu'ils avaient
conquis the depuis le le 24 février
mais on a quand même tendance à oublier
une chose et notamment quand on repense
avec notre offensive de Carson c'est
qu'effectivement il y a eu cette avancée
très rapide qui s'est faite à partir du
moment où en fait les Russes ont décidé
de pas tenir et de réussir à replier le
trouble ça c'est quand
c'était donc en septembre octobre
2022 mais on oublie que la
contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans la région de Kerson
avait commencé dès le mois de mai 2022
et qu'au départ je me souviens les
commentaires c'était ah bah les les
Ukrainiens sont passés à l'offensive et
ça n'avance pas et en réalité vous voyez
dans la zone bleue dans la zone Carson
il y avait une rivière qui s'appelle
lingoulette les Russes ont tenues très
très longtemps cette ligne de front il y
avait à peu près 30000 à 40000 soldats
russes dans cette dans cette zone ils
ont tenu longtemps les Ukrainiens ont
mis beaucoup de temps à avoir une ligne
de pont une tête de pont pardon sur
cette sur scène rivière et ça s'est joué
en moi alors
le principe de cariffe c'était différent
elle a été pour le coup fulgurant mais
celle de Carson il faut pas oublier
qu'elle s'est joué si on démarre donc
je n'afficherai aucune certitude à ce
stade ce qui est clair c'est qu'il y a
une deuxième en fait une troisième étape
de la contre-offensive
lancé le 8 juin c'est à dire que au
début on a été étonné de voir que les
Ukrainiens sont allés tout de suite à
l'assaut avec des forces blindées ils
sont rendus compte très vite que ça
marchait pas donc ils sont ils ont
stoppé cette phase offensive pour
revenir à une stratégie plus classique
de de guerre d'artillerie pour affaiblir
les arrières russes avec une guerre
d'infanterie qui continuait
sur la ligne de front et là depuis 48
heures il semblerait qu'il y ait une
troisième face c'est-à-dire que de
nouveau le s'active avec des unités
blindées juste un dernier point parce
que les ordres de grandeur c'est
important
les estimations qu'on a de cette
offensive majeure depuis 48 heures on
parle de quelques bataillons peut-être
trois
avec quelques dizaines de chars et de
blindés c'est important ça n'est pas non
plus une masse
considérable les Ukrainiens conservent
un certain nombre de un grand nombre
même de de
brigades en réserve les Russes ont aussi
des réserves stratégiques alors qu'ils
sont pas très loin mais simplement elles
sont pas sur la ligne de front elles
sont à 50 80 km au sud voilà donc c'est
les jeunes sont pas faits il faut de la
patience effectivement on a une on a
plusieurs questions on a Machiavel et
qui nous dit que ça lui fait plaisir de
nous retrouver ben nous aussi on est on
est heureux de vous retrouver et on nous
invite d'ailleurs à poser vos questions
dans le chat Thomas chiref qui nous
demande nous parler de cette flèche
rouge donc c'est une
une offensive russe qui vient du qui
vient du nord absolument
alors c'est un truc qu'il faut pas
oublier qui inquiétait beaucoup les
Ukrainiens en tout cas le discours
officiel ukrainien il y a une dizaine de
jours et c'est la région
dont je vous dis qu'il ne fallait pas
l'oublier
celle de coupure qui est de celle de
celle de car kiff et il y a cette ville
symbolique de coupure et il est vrai
qu'à cet endroit là il y a une
contre-attaque russe mais alors il faut
préciser qu'en réalité les Russes
exercent une pression
sur ce front du Nord on va l'appeler du
Nord l'Ukraine mais au nord du
dispositif depuis en réalité l'hiver
il n'avait pas réussi pressé mais il
n'avait pas réussi à percer depuis
quelques semaines on observe une avancée
de quelques kilomètres c'est à dire que
à la fois réussi à s'approcher de
coupure ce qui et vous voyez ensuite
la ligne de France décale vers l'est et
en fait à cet endroit là il y a une il y
a une autre rivière La dirait bête et là
les Russes ont réussi à la franchir et
avancer de quelques kilomètres ça n'est
pas massif donc la même prudence pour
les Russes qui allait garder des
Ukrainiens j'ai envie que en revanche le
tempo n'est probablement pas le même les
Ukrainiens ont un objectif stratégique
qui est de percer complètement le fond
du Sud et grosso modo d'arriver jusqu'à
la mer d'Azov pour couper le dispositif
russe en deux
je ne suis pas sûr que dans la région de
campiance les Russes là aujourd'hui avec
le le
contre-offensive leur offensive ou leur
attaque et un objectif réellement
stratégique en tout cas à court au moyen
terme simplement c'est leur permet
d'exercer une pression forte sur ce
cette partie du front qui est un peu
oubliée et donc les Ukrainiens
100 000 soldats russes 900 chars
d'assaut
c'est pas impossible encore une fois les
rues sont des réserves et les Russes ont
réalisé une mobilisation partielle au
mois de septembre dernier
malgré tout on s'attend pas aujourd'hui
après l'histoire est faite de surprises
on s'attend pas à une grande offensive
russe dans cette région c'est surtout
pour fixer des Ukrainiens et grignoter
un peu et solidifier leur ligne de front
à cet endroit là est-ce que vous êtes le
nombre de de force en présence des deux
côtés les réserves aussi qui existent
pour les deux
c'est très compliqué de donner des
chiffres
vous souvenez que le dispositif russe au
tout départ de la guerre en Ukraine on
estimait qu'il y avait entre 150000 et
200000 euros ce qui était rentrés en
Ukraine ce qui était terriblement peu
pour une guerre qui comprenait
l'intégralité de l'Ukraine entre temps
il y a eu une mobilisation partielle
c'est-à-dire avec des
avec des des
mobilisés et depuis il y a pas eu de
remobilisation mais les les Russes font
état de
[Musique]
de contrat de contractuel qui
régulièrement rentrent dans l'armée
russe si vous voulez les ordres de
grandeur c'est qu'il y a entre 300 et
000 grands maximum soldat russe
dans
pris dans la dans l'opération militaire
spécial ça ce sont les ans de grandeur
et en face du côté ukrainien les ordres
de grandeur sont probablement les mêmes
là où c'est compliqué de donner des
chiffres comme ça c'est que il y a les
grandes masses et puis il y a les masses
plus faibles qu'on a réellement formé
par exemple combien a-t-on formé
d'ukrainien pour la contre-offensive la
force de manœuvre dont on dispose les
Ukrainiens pour mener leur offensive
principalement dans le sud de combien
est-elle bon bah les
Occidentaux auraient formé entre 60 et
Ukrainiens donc vous voyez ça donne une
idée de la force de manœuvre de la même
manière les occidentaux
ce sont engagés d'ores et déjà à fournir
environ 150 chars qui sont des chars
modernes occidentaux donc des léopards
allemands quelques challengers
britanniques
dans les Léopards il y a la fois des
léopards 2 qui sont réellement modernes
mais attention il y a des léopards 1 qui
sont des vieux chats des années 60-70
de même ça tombe de pays occidentaux
d'Europe de l'Est qui avait encore dans
leur stock des chats ex soviétiques de
type T72
en ont envoyé aussi vous voyez les
ordres de grandeur
c'est que les Ukrainiens peuvent
mobiliser peut-être 300 400 chars
dans l'absolu ce sont des chiffres qui
sont relativement faibles
et donc il faut les les avoir
à l'esprit quand on pense à cette
contre-offensive
le scénario de l'effondrement du front
russe
pour l'instant ne semble il peut arriver
sont pas c'est pas le scénario on va
dire majoritaire les Russes étaient dans
un état de fébrilité beaucoup plus grand
par exemple la dernière pourquoi parce
que il n'avait pas encore mobilisé et
rappelez-vous ils avaient mobilisé et on
avait dit oui mais cette mobilisation
c'est du personnel qui n'est pas formé
ils n'ont pas d'équipement
suffisamment
[Musique]
important à la fois en termes qualités
et quantitatif finalement pour armer
cette grande masse de 300 000 hommes on
se rend compte que malgré tous les
Russes ont réussi à établir une ligne de
défense qui est qui est solide et même
même les Américains les Ukrainiens le
reconnaissent sans difficulté
si vous voulez il y a deux possibilités
soit cette contre-offensive et
véritablement une guerre de manœuvre
où là l'objectif c'est de reprendre du
territoire dans les semaines dans les
mois qui viennent pour arriver un
résultat stratégique ou les Ukrainiens
c'est la mère d'Azov est coupé le
dispositif en deux soit on reste dans le
cadre plus général d'une guerre
d'attrition c'est à dire que chacun des
protagonistes des délices essayent
d'affaiblir l'autre et au bout d'un
moment il y a un rapport de force et un
rapport de de feu qui fera que l'un aura
gagné par usure contre l'autre
et pour l'instant
depuis quelques semaines on avait
l'impression que les Ukrainiens étaient
rentrés dans une logique d'être ici là
il y a une logique de manoeuvre depuis
quelques années mais il faut raison
garder et attendre
si vous êtes question de la pression un
point important qui avait été soulevé
dans un article de méta défense qui a un
site consacré aux questions militaires
c'est que on sait que l'attrition russe
c'est-à-dire la
perte de à la fois en homme et en
équipement des Russes et notamment en
équipements parce qu'il est plus
facilement mesurable et absolument
colossal les Russes ont perdu
visuellement confirmés plus de 2000
chars c'est absolument
considérable qu'on réfléchit aux ordres
de grandeur dont on pense depuis tout à
l'heure la France dispose de 200 chars
Leclerc et encore les deux sens ne sont
pas tous opérationnels
et donc on s'était dit peut-être que les
Russes vont arriver à court de char
d'assaut de munitions de blindés ou de
munitions ou que sais-je
et cet article de méta défense analyser
dans le temps
notamment le fait que ces derniers mois
dans les dans les dans les véhicules
détruits et bien il y avait un grand
nombre de véhicules qui avaient été
produits
ces dernières semaines ou ces derniers
mois alors il y a deux manières de voir
les choses soit on se disant ce matériel
qui vient de sortir
n'est pas efficace mais il y a une autre
chose une autre manière de voir les
choses c'est que les russes arrivent à
envoyer sur le front
un certain nombre de matériels qui
viennent alors quand je dis construit
c'est que c'est pas forcément du matelas
neuf ça peut être des vieux stocks
soviétiques qui ont été modernisés c'est
l'été 72 l'été 62 par exemple qui sont
très vieux ça T62 mise en service en 62
mais qui ont été remis au goût du jour
alors c'est des modernations légères
mais en tout cas c'est du matériel qui
n'était pas opérationnel et qui le
redevient parce qu'il y a une
mobilisation industrielle en Russie
elle a encore une fois on n'a pas la fin
de l'histoire mais il y a il y a bien
des résultats sur le sur l'appareil
industriel de défense russe qui trito en
économie de guerre il tourne on est
connu de guerre et qui porte ses fruits
est-ce que ça pas suffisant ça c'est une
autre question et tout d'ailleurs on n'a
pas réellement
la différence entre la pression
ukrainienne et la pression russe donc ni
la dynamique et donc on ne peut pas dire
aujourd'hui
le tel des deux protagonistes va gagner
cette guerre forcément alors il y a une
question de Magic mood sur les sur les
pertes mais avant ça je voulais quand
même vous poser une question parce qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure de est-ce que le
front peut s'effondrer est-ce qu'on a
des informations sur une hausse des
désertions dans l'armée russe c'est
quelque chose qu'on entend depuis le
début du conflit aucune information mais
est-ce que c'est ce sont des ce sont des
faits extrêmement rares on va dire ou
pas j'ai aucune information qui qui
serait chiffrée solide on a eu
localement des des preuves des preuves
plus ou moins étayées de de
soldats qui semblent on a eu des preuves
aussi du côté ukrainien
je pense que là de dire quelque chose
qui serait fondé sur ce sujet là c'est
très très compliqué Magic mood qui nous
demande du coup est-ce qu'on a une idée
des pertes des deux belligérants
là aussi c'est très compliqué d'avoir
des chiffres c'est très compliqué on va
reprendre
les chiffres
chiffres américains les chiffres
occidentaux de manière générale les
estimes alors le problème c'est que nos
pertes il y a pas que des morts les
morts les blessés
et puis les personnes capturées ou
disparus mais les estimations du côté
russe et de 100000
à 200 000 soldats ce qui est assez dire
cohérent avec les évaluations en termes
de masse dont on parlait
tout à l'heure étant donné qu'il y a eu
une mobilisation partielle entre temps
côté
ukrainien bah là encore il y a une
bataille de chiffres
disons que les ordres de grandeur vont
de 50000 à 150
000 si on regarde les chiffres ou
occidentaux les Russes évidemment
avancent des chiffres beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus élevés alors je vais
parler aussi des en tout cas si on si on
estime qu'il y a une corrélation entre
les pertes en homme et les pertes de
matériel
là il me semble pour le coup
parfaitement avéré que la pression russe
est beaucoup plus élevée que la
tradition
ukrainienne d'accord mais il faut voir
que c'est pas forcément comparable c'est
dire que les Russes sont beaucoup plus
de profondeur de stock grâce à l'Union
soviétique ils ont aussi un appareil
industriel de défense qui est fondée sur
la masse
alors que les Ukrainiens pour des
raisons évidentes par eux-mêmes ils ont
le plus grand mal à fabriquer des armes
qui dépendent des Occidentaux et le
modèle
occidental c'est beaucoup plus des
armées d'échantillons avec des
équipements
beaucoup plus technologiques donc on va
parler sur la sur la qualité plus que
sur la quantité et donc quand les
Ukrainiens perdent par exemple
un char léopard c'est pas pareil ça n'a
pas la même valeur que quand les Russes
perdent un Chartier 62 qui est assez
antique on a une question de en thème
Mania alors je sais pas parce que c'est
pas forcément très précis sa question
mais je pense que je la comprends il me
demande si les Ukrainiens ont progressé
suite à cette asso ou ont été stoppé
donc je pense qu'il parle de la de 48 de
la salle dans le sud je peux pas vous
donner une réponse complètement
affirmative il semblerait qu'ils ont
avancé quelques kilomètres quand on dit
quelques kilomètres c'est de l'ordre de
1 2 3 4 quelque chose comme ça voilà je
peux pas être plus précis et il
semblerait qu'il y ait
quelques villages vous voyez les deux
axes j'en ai parlé il y a aurekki v d'un
côté et un peu plus à l'aise
velikanova Silka et alors vers au Reiki
ils auraient pris un certain nombre de
de village le problème c'est qu'il y a
des zones grises en plus mais
peut-être quelques villages au sud de
rekkif qui auparavant étaient du côté
russe
et du côté plus à l'Est entre deux
nièces et
et ça pourrait déjà je vous ai cité ce
village de Starro Majorque
il faut conserver un peu de dans
l'analyse de de distance parce que sinon
on se sinon on se perd et on a tendance
à mal
mesuré l'importance d'une d'une avancée
vous avancer de kilomètres aujourd'hui
mais en général quand il y a une attaque
le lendemain il y a une contre-attaque
et en fait l'attaque notre valeur que si
vous arrivez à résister à la
contre-attaque du langage
il faut raisons garder je voulais parler
aussi de des attaques en profondeur des
deux systèmes c'est-à-dire que on voit
je vais vous montrer voilà la Crimée et
odsa qui sont deux endroits qui sont
loin de ligne de front et pourtant qui
sont bombardés au dessin par exemple
très récemment la cathédrale de dessin
était bombardée
et il y a la d'ailleurs le président
ukrainien y était récemment alors avec
deux choses différentes
les frappes ukrainiennes sont vraiment
des frappes
aviser vraiment militaires qu'à chaque
fois on voit ce qu'il frappe
c'est affaiblir la logistique russe les
dépôts de munitions les chemins de fer
les ponts ce genre de choses là voir des
masses de soldats qu'auraient eu la
mauvaise idée de se réunir en trop grand
nombre
et donc ça on le voit très je vous
parlais de bataille d'artillerie le but
des Ukrainiens qui le problème c'est que
les Ukrainiens ils ont peu ils peuvent
tirer moins de bus que les Russes mais
leur système d'artillerie qui sont
occidentaux en partie sont plus précis
et portent plus loin que les Russes et
donc ils essayent
finalement de de d'atténuer l'avantage
russe qui est celui de la masse en
termes d'artillerie donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont cibler les dépôts de
munitions
cibler même les les pièces d'artillerie
grâce à la précision etc pour essayer de
remporter cette cette bataille
d'artillerie et il semblerait que le
niveau
de le rapport de feu le rapport de feu
c'est à dire le le feu la masse des
furus versus la masse des feu Ukrainiens
ce soir rééquilibré en faveur de
l'Ukraine et donc il y a un certain
nombre d'observateurs colonel Michel
gouya qui a remarqué que cette bataille
d'artillerie qui est beaucoup plus
discrète beaucoup moins spectaculaire
typiquement on va pas voir sur la carte
une avancée avec du bleu ou du rouge que
sais-je cette bataille d'artillerie plus
discrète aujourd'hui les
Ukrainiens semblent avoir l'avantage en
la matière et c'est peut-être parce
qu'ils ont pris l'avantage dans la
matière qu'ils ont relancé depuis 48
heures des opérations qui sont des
opérations d'assaut avec du matériel
blindé etc et pardon sur les frappes
dans la profondeur russe
c'est des frappes beaucoup plus
politiques souvent par exemple là bon la
cathédrale de des sages ne sépare quel
était la motivation des Russes elle est
inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO c'est
c'est un drame culturel et cette guerre
aussi absolument terrible pour le pour
le patrimoine mais au-delà de ça les
rues sont beaucoup
ciblés à Odessa
les réserves de grains grainiens et donc
là c'est tout un autre volet beaucoup
plus géopolitique de la guerre en
Ukraine dont on parle de plusieurs
semaines maintenant qui est le blocus
que les Russes exercent en mer Noire sur
le maintenant qu'ils sont sortis de de
l'accord plutôt ils n'ont pas ils n'ont
pas renouvelé l'accord sur le grain sur
les céréales qui avait été passé entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie avec une un entre
gens qui étaient plutôt turc et qui
permettait à l'Ukraine
de continuer d'exporter une partie de
son grain en passant par la mer Noire et
donc là non les Russes sont rétablis
blocus naval
absolument c'était le même jeu
on a Machiavel qui me demande c'est où
pourquoi les Ukrainiens ne bombardent
pas plus les chemins de fer pour bloquer
complètement la logistique russe sur la
région de zapporisia
ils le font un peu
s'ils le font pas complètement c'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure c'est
premièrement
premièrement les
Ukrainiens
n'ont pas des réserves en termes de
munitions qui sont qui sont
considérables rappelons que les obus
que les Ukrainiens utilisent pour
frapper dans la profondeur
les équipements russes c'est des obus
guidés
qui valent extrêmement cher c'est des ça
ressemble à un obus classique mais c'est
un objet extrêmement technologique les
Russes en face ont un certain nombre de
buts guidés mais mais la plupart des
obus qu'ils utilisent c'est des obus
classiques qui coûte absolument rien à
fabriquer dès lors qu'on a les chaînes
de production
pour les fabriquer
premièrement de réponse deuxième élément
de réponse faut pas oublier non plus que
les Russes ont un système de défense
on tire rien aérien au sens vraiment
général de tout ce qui vient du ciel qui
malgré tout assez perfectionné
les Russes historiquement
avaient quand même très grand expérience
en la matière et donc le les Russes
visiblement ont réussi aussi à s'adapter
face à la menace
qui vient du ciel l'Ukrainien mais non
pas d'avion mais mais de systèmes
d'artillerie à longue portée tels que
les highmars ou maintenant un certain
nombre de de missiles on pense Shadow
britannique maintenant les Français ont
aussi
livrés
ici l'équivalent qui est un missile
airsol
et donc si vous voulez la
guerre c'est une dialectique donc les
donc les les Russes ce sont aussi
adaptés à cette menace là par rapport au
tout début qu'on soit apparu les imams
on voyait bien que les Russes
n'arrivaient pas à intercepter les
neymars aujourd'hui évidemment ils
interceptent pas tout
toutes les
projectiles des imams qui tirent à 80 km
de portée mais ils arrivent à arrêter un
certain nombre d'entre eux
on a en thème Mania qui demande ce qui
nous pose une question sur les récentes
frappes de drone sur Moscou on se
rappelle des images données par le
Kremlin quel était le quel était le but
de
ces manœuvres là pour le coup c'est très
politique là je vous dis je vous disais
tout à l'heure que les frappes
ukrainiennes dans la profondeur viser
vraiment des dispositifs militaires là
on était
quelque chose de beaucoup plus politique
et d'ailleurs chose très intéressante
l'attaque en elle-même n'a pas eu une
portée extraordinaire ne va pas changer
le cours de la guerre
en revanche ce qui est nouveau c'est que
les Ukrainiens ont immédiatement
revendiqué l'attaque contre Moscou donc
là si vous voulez c'est un changement
d'attitude de Kiev et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les Américains
se sont immédiatement ils n'ont pas
condamné en terme diplomatique ça aurait
été évidemment beaucoup trop fort
mais ils n'ont pas soutenu
cette action
ukrainienne contre la capitale russe
j'ai une question aussi sur Wagner sur
que devient que devient Wagner que
devient frigorne on se rappelle de cette
remontée des forces de Wagner vers
quelques heures quelques heures et qu'en
est-il maintenant que les militaires de
Wagner par exemple que sont-ils devenus
alors déjà
va résoudre la question relative à la
guerre en Ukraine
en fait les troubles de Wagner dès la
prise de bac mouth c'était retiré et à
ce moment-là on estimait qu'il y avait
peut-être 15000 ou 20 000 combattants de
Wagner avec un peu de matériel lourd
mais enfin c'est principalement des
forces d'assaut donc de l'infanterie
en réalité au moment du coup je sais pas
comment l'appelait une sorte de coup
d'éclat plutôt que de coup d'état
décla raté
les troubles de Wagner étaient déjà plus
sur le front donc ça n'a pas eu et ça
n'aura pas
d'effets directs sur la sur la guerre en
Ukraine
on se souvient qu'il y a eu un accord
qui a été passé sous l'égide de
Loukachenko le président biélorusse et
que
trigogine de véhêtre accueilli entre
guillemets un peu en exil en Biélorussie
or hier on va utiliser le conditionnel
mais il semblerait que prégogène était
bien à Saint-Pétersbourg
Afrique Russie de Russie donc à
Saint-Pétersbourg avec 19 chefs d'État
je crois africains plus Poutine ça
montre qu'il a encore un rôle à jouer
parce que c'était
Wagner et si vous voulez Wagner les le
vecteur de l'influence russe en Afrique
et donc on voit que trigogine a encore
un jouet un rôle à jouer avec son groupe
de de mercenaires
notamment sur les sur les questions
africaines
il y a eu plusieurs choses qui sont
observables notamment
un début de purge
dans le commandement militaire russe le
général Popov
qui a été limogé parce qu'il avait
critiqué très très ouvertement
la stratégie militaire russe en
Ukraine il y a eu beaucoup de rumeurs à
propos de souris qui est le commandant
adjoint de l'opération militaire spécial
qui est un peu on a dit qu'il était
qu'il avait été en prisonnier
c'est pas complètement certain enfin
c'est probable ou en tout cas il est
sorti des radars ce qui est intéressant
c'est que lui-même n'avait pas soutenu
Prigogine
mais on dit qu'en sous main bref voilà
il lui-même est un ancien pucc cheese de
1991 donc tradition personnelle
et puis dernièrement vous savez en
Russie il y a les blogueurs militaire
qui sont des
nationalistes entre guillemets ils sont
pour la plupart entre guillemets la
droite de Poutine il trouve que Poutine
a un peu la main molle
et il y a un d'entre eux
Igor girkin un ancien séparatiste prorus
de de la guerre du don-basse de 2014 et
qui aujourd'hui enfin n'a plus de rôle
officiel et qui a un ancien officier
d'enseignement et qui lui a été arrêté
vendredi dernier à Moscou parce qu'il
était allé clairement trop loin il avait
dit que Poutine était lâche là je suis
faible enfin je sais
long terme comme ça
mais si vous voulez c'était dans un
contexte un peu de de purge ou ministère
de la Défense on avait marre d'être
critiqué voilà donc c'est shoego qui
essaie de reprendre la main
mais ça s'il essaie de reprendre la main
ça montre quand même temps on interne il
y a du vide il y a il y a des tensions
sur la stratégie en
Ukraine avec un parti de la guerre qui
est favorable à une mobilisation
peut-être pas générale mais mais en tout
cas une nouvelle mobilisation de la
population en Russie on se souvient il y
a quelques semaines il y a toute une
partie de la communauté de défense en
Russie
qui parle de manière assez précise de
l'emploi de d'armes nucléaire tactique
en Ukraine on voit qu'il y a un parti de
la guerre en Russie qui est à la droite
de de Poutine donc Wagner faut le
comprendre là-dedans sachant que
reparlera un tout petit peu de la
Biélorussie donc les les de Wagner qui
n'ont qui ont refusé d'intégrer les
rangs de l'armée russe
ont pu rejoindre leur chef en
Biélorussie alors chef visiblement et
pas tout le temps bien aussi mais en
tout cas eux sont allés dans un camp en
Biélorussie accueilli entre guillemets
par Lucas and Co et notamment ils sont
allés s'entraîner dans un camp qui est à
5 km de la frontière ukrainienne et il y
a eu des déclarations de
Lukachenko disant que les Gad Wagner
avaient envie d'aller
vers Varsovie il faut raisons garder
propagande de guerre
je crois qu'il y a quelque chose comme
comme
mercenaires de Wagner dans ce camp Liège
W qui est un institut
américain
les photos satellites ils n'ont plus
aucun matériel lourd parce que tout le
matériel lourd a été saisi par l'armée
russe ils ont des camions et des 4 4
c'est pas avec ça qu'ils vont aller à
Varsovie mais
c'est pour créer une tension c'est de
l'ordre une sorte de provocation il y a
c'est à la fois l'adresse des pays
occidentaux et sans même temps de la
communication interne à la fois de
Loukachenko et de Poutine qui ont envie
d'entretenir
ce parfum de guerre dont ils ont besoin
pour leur
en tout cas Poutine pour son opération
militaire spéciale on parle de la
politique interne ce côté russe est-ce
que côté ukrainien par exemple vous avez
une ski et
en terme à l'intérieur de son pays et
toujours aussi soutenu par sa population
pour l'instant on ne voit pas de
fissures dans le dans la dans l'appareil
ukrainien
c'est plutôt là encore il faut attendre
un peu
la vraie question qui va se poser c'est
quid dans quelques mois de la
contre-offensive
ukrainienne oui parce que si jamais si
tout cela se retrouve elle ne fonctionne
pas
les Occidentaux ont donné quand même
énormément de matériel
à l'Ukraine ils ont réussi à former une
force de manœuvre de 60 70 000 hommes
avec des centaines de chars des encore
plus de blindés des centaines de pièces
d'artillerie
qu'est-ce qui feront après si ça ça ne
marche pas
c'est là où une question politique va se
poser parce que les Ukrainiens
politiquement zenki aujourd'hui devant
son peuple ne peut pas se suffire
d'une ligne de front qui se figerait et
qui mine de rien mais ça serait une
victoire honteux honteuse honteux au
sens où
à très glorieuse pour gagner un petit
mais enfin
si le conflit est gelé à cet endroit là
bah il aura malgré tout avancé un peu
par rapport à ce qu'il y avait pris en
2014 alors à un prix exorbitant ce qui
fait que parler de victoire serait
compliqué mais en tout cas il aurait
pris des dizaines de milliers de
kilomètres carrés en plus en Ukraine et
donc c'est à l'automne que le sujet
politique va se va se poser et la grande
question ça sera l'attitude des
États-Unis
est-ce que ils vont vouloir remettre une
pièce dans la machine là on est dans le
cas où la contre-offensive ne fonctionne
pas est-ce que ils vont vouloir remettre
une pièce dans la machine mais là avec
quel équipement est-ce qu'il faut encore
augmenter en termes financier l'anal
Ukraine
où est-ce que
s'il y a vraiment rien d'ici la fin de
l'année 2023 est-ce qu'on va s'orienter
vers des négociations entre les
Occidentaux et les Russes et dans ce cas
là
quelle va être comment va se positionner
les Ukrainiens par rapport à cela
est-ce qu'il y aura deux camps qui vont
apparaître quand favorables négociations
un campus
dans les mois prochains il faut avoir
l'esprit mais pour l'instant ça reste
des scénarios dans la mesure où tout ça
dépend de l'issue de la contrepensive
ukrainienne juste avant des grandes
dates en tête
élection russe et américaine
résidentielles en 2024
élection
ukrainienne je veux pas dire de bêtises
présidentielle en 2025
et toujours en 2025 me semble-t-il je
suis quasiment certain sinon c'est un an
après élection présidentielle en
Biélorussie donc vous voyez il y a un
contexte international et régional qui
peut être amené à changer énormément
dans les années à venir et
ça risque d'avoir des implications
fortes
effectivement on a une question de que
j'essaie de retrouver Magic mood qui
demande souvent des États-Unis je tiens
américains qui nous parle des F16
est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut lui donner
notre avis sur l'utilisation des F16 par
les Ukrainiens alors déjà les Américains
ont été clairs les FC ne vont pas
arriver comme par miracle même dans les
mois qui viennent et inverser le rapport
de force de la contre-offensive mais on
le dit depuis le début il n'y a pas des
équipements
entraîner les hommes et par ailleurs si
vous arrivez avec un escadron de F-16
ça va pas changer le cours de la guerre
il faudrait c'est un véritable impact il
faudrait reconstituer une véritable
force aérienne
ukrainienne il y a toujours un résidu
les Ukrainiens ont toujours quelques
sous coïn 24 quelques
sous-couilles 25 quelques minutes 29 etc
etc mais si vous voulez les Russes donc
quasiment pas utilisé leur armée de
l'air
à part les appareils d'attaque au sol et
que ça soit des avions ou des
hélicoptères mais si vous voulez la
grande masse des des chasseurs
multiroals
russes n'ont pas été utilisés
35 mais 29 etc donc les deux mêmes que
les Russes ne peuvent pas aller en
profondeur dans le territoire ukrainien
parce qu'il y a des défenses aériennes
ukrainiennes de même de manière
symétrique si les Ukrainiens avaient
quelques F-16 il ne pourraient pas les
facilement sur le territoire russe qui
est couvert de défense aériennes alors
avec d'énormes ratés on a vu que les
drones
Ukrainiens arrivent à
passer
mais des drones aussi
les défenses aériennes russes parfois
ont été pensées pour des plus gros pour
des aéronefs beaucoup plus gros
d'un drone c'est beaucoup plus petit que
[Musique]
c'est une signature aussi thermique
beaucoup plus petite ça va moins vite
etc donc je veux dire les F-16 ne vont
pas changer la donne ça rentrera dans
une question plus large qui est
en fonction des résultats de la
contre-offensive qu'est-ce qu'on veut
pour l'Ukraine
et selon ce qu'on veut qu'est-ce qu'on
leur apporte effectivement
je pense qu'on a fait le tour des
questions de ce live merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
d'avoir été très nombreux encore une
fois à nous poser des questions et bien
sûr on vous en reparlera à la prochaine
prochaine informations qui tombent
forcément avec cette contre-offensive
qui bien sûr on suivra et on attend bien
sûr l'automne on a plus pour la compris
c'est aussi et puis d'ici là je pense
qu'il y aura quand même de l'actualité
notamment sur cette offensive de qui a
démarré il a démarré avec un Twitter
effectivement merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
d'avoir du Figaro je vous donne
rendez-vous à 16h pour la question du
jour à bientôt sur figure live